[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is lindsey wolf and i am a
product manager here at nana select
biomedical
i'm excited to be able to talk to you
today about some of our technology and
most importantly introduce the launch of
our new wolf g2 sales sorter
the most important place to start for
any company is to understand their
customers
it's fine and good to make cool
technology but to make something that
will truly provide value to users you
have to understand the problems that
exist in order to provide a solution
to that end our team at nanaselect went
out and talked to researchers to
understand the scientific community's
style sorting needs after talking to
people from all different types of
organizations doing a wide variety of
applications
some common themes kept coming up
72 percent of respondents said that cell
sorting costs were too much to maintain
55 said that instruments are too complex
and limit efficiency 63 were concerned
about affordability especially for a
system in the lab
especially for complex systems and
systems that cost a lot to maintain as
well
and about half of the people we talked
to had issues with high pressure
conventional cell disorders that damaged
cells or negatively affect experiments
this quote from one of our respondents
was pretty representative of this
concern
they worked with pluripotent stem cells
which were very sensitive and they knew
that single cell sorting can stress
their cells and trigger differentiation
and the act of cell sorting itself can
change gene expression
to meet the needs of affordable simple
and gentle susporting
nanoselects has developed the wolf and
the wolf g2
i'll go more into depth about each of
these but
just as an overview because our
instruments use our unique microfluidic
sorting technology
there's less than 2 psi pressure on
cells keeping them healthy and viable
for downstream assays
our microfluidics
technology also allows for sterile and
disposable cartridges
it is safe no aerosols or sample
carryover
the wolf and the wolf viewer software
simple and intuitive
there's a small footprint for both the
wolf and the wolf g2 and can fit easily
in biosafety hoods
and it's affordable
so not only are the wolf and the wolf g2
part of nanaselek's technology but it's
an entire solution for cell sorting
along with the wolf we have the wolf
viewer software and a computer that also
comes with the wolf
there are microfluidic cartridges that
are provided when the wolf is purchased
as well as for individual experiments
and the n1 single cell dispenser
can be included with the wolf for
customers that are doing single cell
experiments
a key innovation for nanoselect and
really where nano's lights all started
is the microfluidic cartridge so we have
two types of cartridges
a bulk sorting cartridge and a single
cell dispensing cartridge which goes on
the single cell the n1 single cell
dispenser
this middle video shows the cell sorting
junction and this is a video of beads
that are flowing through into the
central channel but as they are
triggered by the
by the laser
and the pzt or piezoelectric actuator
they're sorted into that left channel
the pzt
system is actually shown in the cartoon
on the right
and you can see that a positive or
negative charge
allows for cells or any particle to be
sorted into um the a or b
uh channels
so low pressure sorting is important
because conventional cell sorters like
cuvette or jet and air sorters
exert 20 to 70 square inches per pound
of pressure on your cells
which as they exit the nozzle result in
decompression shock
our wolf however emits only
two units of pressure on cells so
there's no decompression shock once they
exit out of the cartridge system
your cells end up being much happier and
healthier and functional for downstream
assays
the closed system is also important for
a couple other reasons it's really easy
the setup is quick it's simple to run
and when you're finished with your
experiment
all you have to do is remove and dispose
of the cartridge and turn off the
instrument
there are no aerosols
so it's safer for use with any sort of
biohazardous material
and there's no cross-contamination
between samples which is important for
a lot of different applications
including things like genomic sample
prep
using our low pressure closed system
along with wolf which was launched in
2017
users have been able to do a lot that
they might otherwise not have been able
to accomplish easily
as our customers have gotten comfortable
with the wolf though they've realized
they want to use it for more a simple
one laser system is great for many many
things but we realize that nanoslug's
technology should be available to a
wider audience for a wider set of
applications
thus we are launching the wolf g2
so the wolf has one laser a 488
nanometer laser five detectors back and
forward scatter and three fluorescent
channels
both the wolf and the wolf g2 are
compact sit on the bench top and use our
sterile cartridges which are
the instruments and the cartridges are
low maintenance
the wolf g2 however
has two lasers and three different
instrument configurations
all three configurations have a 488
nanometer laser
but one has a additional four or five
nanometer laser one has a 561 and the
third has a 637 nanometer laser alvin
has seven detectors
um back and forward scatter five
fluorescent detectors and up to nine
fluorescent channels
increased sensitivity and improved
usability there's rfid tags for
cartridge serial numbers and expiration
dates
and the instrument is easy to move
around the lab and the country
so
here are the three laser configurations
and some of the fluorophores that can be
used for them
on the left is the 488 and 405 nanometer
laser configuration
you can see that for the 488 nanometer
laser it's great with
fitzy gfp
pe uh 7ad for viability
um but now the 488 can be used for for
example brilliant violet dives
bfp or cfp and dappy
the 561
488 can now be used with
anterior and rfp really well
um and then the
637 and 488 on the relays are can be
used with now apc and apc size 7 just to
name a couple of the most common things
that people will use but there's a
there's a wide variety
of fluorophores that are now available
to customers that weren't necessarily as
efficient on the single laser 488 wolf
the wolf g2 is an important tool for a
variety of different workflows and can
help improve the efficiency of research
i'll go through a little bit of data in
the next few slides that some of the
applications for the wolf g2 will be
important
are for one cell line development
using for example dna variant libraries
to sort and single cell dispense on the
n1
for efficiency of viable cells and
better outgrowth to identify optimized
cell lines
for genomics
improving sample prep by excluding
debris and dead cells but gentle enough
to avoid affecting gene expression
for gene editing to sort and plate
single crispr edited cells for improved
workflow efficiency and also being able
to sort
especially sensitive cells like induced
pluripotent stem cells to avoid shear
stress and
improve viability
for immunology especially with the two
lasers being able to sort more colors
in this example single single antigen
specific b cell sorting
and for infectious disease with the wolf
g2 and n1 being able to be used inside a
biosafety cabinet
to be able to use in higher bsl
laboratories to sort infectious cells or
cells transfected with infectious
genetic materials safely
the first case study i wanted to talk
about
is
sorting neutrophils for high viability
impurity
neutrophils are the first responders to
microbial infection they are 60 to 70 of
circulating leukocytes
once they're activated they can undergo
phagocytosis
or releasing chromatin fibers to trap
and kill pathogens
it's
important for them to easily activate to
fight infection but it also is one of
the elements that makes them especially
difficult to sort
even when they're not activated they die
quickly when they're in circulation
uh making them very difficult to isolate
in general
and all of these factors
are
uh
make them difficult to sort but actually
make them ideal for using one wolf
and it's gentle cell sorting
our team was able to employ their
expertise and experimental design to
isolate neutrons for high viability and
high purity
we chose a buffer to present prevent
undue activation and keep cells happy as
well as double biomarkers for both
neutrophil positive and dead cell
negative sorting
you can see that the purity of the top
left population of live neutrophils does
increase from just under 32 to over 97
which is a more than three-fold increase
in addition you can see that only 1.4 of
the cells are fl1 positive indicating
off target or dead cells which indicates
that the wolf had a very low impact on
neutrophil viability
the purity of the neutrophil population
is confirmed to be a scatter on the
right side of the slide but just over 95
pure granulocyte population which
as i indicated earlier is primarily made
up of neutrophils so this is a very good
indicator that the staining really does
reflect high nitrophil purity
in the next two case studies i'll be
discussing pbmc sorting
starting with how the wolf can be used
for higher quality rna seek data with
the 10x chromium workflow
for high quality single cell genomics
and rna sync data it's vital to start
with high quality sample pro
high percent of healthy cells for
genomic library prep
means higher rna quality which means
better sequencing results
not only do you want to start use cell
sorting to remove dead cells and free
and doublets but you also want to make
sure the sorting itself doesn't affect
gene expression and thus
skew the sequencing results
performing a sample cleanup prior to
loading your sample into the crimean
controller is the best way to get the
most out of your money and
avoid sequencing dead cells
the wolf's disposable cartridges also
allow for no cross contamination between
stamp samples
and style working conditions
in this experiment the wolf was used
upstream of the 10x chromium single cell
controller after sorting through the
wolves the cells were then spun down to
concentrate to chromium specifications
and moved forward to the rest of the
protocol
we wanted to compare the wolf to a
conventional cell sorter in this case
the bd facts aria
to show how it compares to
single cell rna seq results
in this case also using single cell
rna-seq with the 10x genomics platform
for median genes per cell which
essentially means library complexity
the wolf outperformed the aria and the
unsorted sample
for a medium umi counts per cell which
shows the variance sensitivity the wolf
again out computed the aria and unsorted
sample
and then
for higher sample purity or
percent reads mapped to the
transcriptome the wolf again
had an improved efficiency compared to
the aria and unsorted cells
in this third case study also using pvmc
and this time
using the wolf g2
we wanted to show
an increased number of colors
so in this case it's a five color sort
starting with
pbmcs and sorting for cd4 or cd8 t cells
we gated for
lymphocytes and then singlets
and then leukocytes so the cd45 positive
cells t cells for cd3 positive cd19
negative
and then cd4 and cd8 positive
cell populations
also we wanted to show that these cd4
and cd8 t-cell populations were enriched
um starting actually earlier uh
back at the lymphocyte and singlet gates
um starting with a presort the cd8 t
cells were enriched to
about 92 percent from a 14 target
population and the cd4 t cells were
enriched it's a 92 percent from a
26.5
top population so that is three to seven
times
enrichment
for these t cells
so
to sum up uh
i hope i've been able to convey the
benefits of the wolf and the wolf g2 and
the entire microfluidic transmitting
system
um and how it improves a wide range of
workflows and is
um
both small and easy to use gentle safe
and sterile and affordable
one thing i also wanted to add is that
we have extensive online resources
and we have
training material manuals tutorials um
basics 404 recommendations tech support
notes um lots of app notes um all of the
applications that i've mentioned
previously we have outputs for all of
them
um and then document documentation
anything that you'd like to uh to really
know and we have an incredible number of
experts in
our field service team and in-house that
would be
available to talk about the wolf g2 or
any of our products
thank you for joining us as we introduce
the wolf and the wolf g2 especially
we're very excited and we can't wait to
see the advances in research and
workflows that it will be able to
improve